hey was geht ab und jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht's gut erstens nee ich bin
nicht geschminkt dass sie falls oder das
sieht so aus als hätte ich irgendwie
also meine haut sieht richtig krass wir
haben bei dem sonnenbrand und zwar sind
wir hier nämlich gerade in österreich
unterwegs am skifahren beim skifahren
wir sind in österreich und rasch
entscheiden
und irgendwie habe ich heute die sonne
unterstützt tut auch ganz schön weh aber
das ist gar nicht thema des heutigen
videos das nicht sollte der jugend das
juckt oder gehen bei sind wir
zusammengekommen um als euch etwas zu
berichten
guck mal da sind welche die haben wir
rein guckt das war nicht immer so lustig
wir sind hier auf seinem balkon und da
oben gibt so eine straße so hoch und
alle menschen gucken einfach in dieses
zimmer rein wenn ich hier zum beispiel
mit einer kamera stehe oder so ja normal
nicht jeder mensch fühlt sich selber die
ganze zeit aber wir leben ja im 21
jahrhundert und da ist das bloggen jahr
eine anerkannte sportart
wir erzählen schon wieder viel zu viel
platz denn eigentlich geht es im
heutigen video nur um eine sache und
zwar in letzter zeit waren wir öfter
zusammen mal irgendwie unterwegs waren
mal hier und mal da und werden auch
dieses jahr noch mal hier und mal dort
hinfahren und ich bin irgendwie so ein
kleiner fan davon wollen ich mache
unglaublich gerne so kleine reisevideos
was heißt klein also die sind ein
schraub wendig und ich finde es auch
wirklich echt cool dass es halt die
möglichkeit gibt sachen zu filmen
heutzutage einfach sachen festzuhalten
die kohl zusammen zu schneiden und dann
entweder im internet zu veröffentlichen
und natürlich auch für mich als eigene
erinnerung an diesen ort das ist ja
eigentlich na und
ja und auf diesem kanal kam vor ungefähr
drei oder vier wochen das erste video
das habe ich aber noch nirgendwo obwohl
ich glaube ich hab's nitsche gepostet
aber die meisten menschen haben erstens
das video noch nicht gesehen und
zweitens den kanal natürlich auch noch
nicht abonniert und das wollte ich
einfach in diesem video mal kurz sagen
damit dass möglichst viele leute sind
also rennt von eurer freundin zur
nächsten freundin zur nächsten freunden
geht sagt einläuten mama du musst hier
den neuen account von alex wie
abonnieren und marie steht auch drin
also ist es auf jeden fall kommen ganz
ganz genau zum beispiel auch hier vom
skiurlaub bin ich auch fleißig am film
und ja da kommt einiges auf dem kanal
deswegen wenn ihr sowas möchte oder
einfach denn wenn ihr mich gern habt
dann geht auf jeden fall jetzt auf den
kanal ich würde sagen sie mal ein kurzer
einblick was da schon online ist und was
vielleicht auch so kommt ja leute
deswegen kann ich das jetzt nicht oft
genug sagen geht auf den kanal abonniert
ihnen ganz oben in der beschreibung auch
am ende verlinkt klick drauf abonnieren
und schaut euch das video an was von
anderen ist ganz wichtig ihr könnt auch
gerne konstruktive kritik darunter
schreiben in die kommentare gewordene
stative mache ich mir mal gesagt haben
also kommentiert fleißig wenn es euch
gefällt gibt da meinen daumen nach oben
könnte auch gern mal euren freunden
zeigen oder so auf jeden fall ist es ein
projekt wo ich wirklich sehr hinter
stehe und mich sehr darauf freue weil
ich super gerne solche videos schneide
ich hoffe das merkt man auch und ich
gebe mir da wirklich echt eine menge
würde deswegen da ist natürlich cool
wenn das möglichst viele leute sehen und
ja das war es eigentlich mit diesem
kurzen video morgen kommt wieder ein
vernünftiges video was ein bisschen
unterhaltsamer ist ich würde sagen folgt
mir auf instagram alex wie und marie
könnt ihr auch folgen und wir sehen uns
dann morgen wieder beide neuen video hat
rein
willst du noch irgendwas zum schluss
sein oder so auf jeden fall vorbei
schöne ferien an die die ferien haben
und ich bin mal gespannt wie lange
dieses wort geht das rohr ist ja das ist
ja noch mit ja
warum feiert man ostern schreibt ist in
die kommentare
weißt du es natürlich jetzt nicht jetzt
muss ich als die kameras man sonst ist
das hier schon aufgelöst